hello fortnight family today we are
playing one of our very own LT m s this
is bike and seek or hidin scoot we
haven't decided on the name yet anyway
here's the rules four of the finest
police officers in the land are tasked
with taking down rogue troublemakers
speeding across the island the other 96
people must stay scooting for the entire
game the only time they can exit their
vehicle is when swimming over water it's
that simple
the storm circle will catch many of them
out so they must always be moving
forward into the next zone please leave
a like and think about subscribing if
you'd like to join the next Meetup
I'll tell you how to do that at the end
enough talking now let's do this my for
traffic cops are first to Polo the bear
I have shutter star to 16
my final traffic cop is teeth can I have
any multi sir it begins ladies and
gentlemen there is a track have you seen
the track it's just above the farm I
want us to meet there please I stank
that bus driver
[Music]
I've got the on screen indicators and
all my words it's just a permanent
circle here's what's going on this game
mode is Eva called bike and seek or hide
and scoot tell me in chat which one you
want back and seek our hiding scoot okay
in fact I'm going to put all your names
in the video right now we are the
traffic cops can you see us with our
weapons there is four of us in total
you'll know it serves because we are not
on a bike you guys have been speeding
around this island and our job is to
murder every last one of you well not
every last one of you one of you will
survive this if you understand this
drive away now good luck everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right we need to give them lots of time
guys so we need to do some cool stuff
while we're waiting this is Tokyo Drift
I think you'll find
[Music]
if I win Oh referee who won me right you
guys stay sort of near so I can see you
in the replay file but let's go murder
people on motorbikes leave the last one
alive good luck everyone
[Music]
you're awesome
you are awesome keep going dude do this
get get away
you got this red thanks for playing
hooky berry I fell Oh Adam
good to see you brother
[Music]
so [ __ ] anybody does my butt look at the
weave in oh my word they they've gone
away I'm pretty happy with that
good riding whoever that was in the
bushes in the bushes unlucky Ryan good
to see dude
[Music]
I really want you sniper rifle can I
bite off you please person with the
sniper rifle can I bite off yeah ah
thank you so much they go in return too
kind
thank you very much appreciate it nope
[Music]
good a big thing driving a little
scooter GG's my friend is one
shake you down thanks for playing the
game today I have a lovely day
[Music]
that looks so cool I hit back I saw hit
back
[Music]
[Applause]
somebody's got splat
[Music]
right let's keep pushing in together
guys the circle is quite small now this
is the last circle where we can shoot
them okay
are you playing out skirts I like your
style salty pancakes I liked it when I
that you pop up as your names in discard
I really like that GG my duty what I
want you to do is go be free live out
there
[Music]
hang on what do we have down here yeah
look at all these guys they need some c4
haha the massacre begins how many how
about six
you can't hide here marshmellow oh maybe
you can survive you could be the one to
get away nope
dude you're going to struggle to get in
I'm gonna I've got faith in you can get
this you can get in before this storm
you can get in before the storm too so
we have two people who are trying to
beat the storm on their speed machines
these BA these motorbikes that go faster
than the speed of light who will get in
first whoever doesn't
we shall eliminate let's watch and find
out insert some cinematic here Adam
[Music]
it's not you it's also not you you just
know there's gonna be somebody idiot
Nintendo Kirby right pickaxes on me now
guys
traffic cops
[Music]
come in you fall thank you for playing
crack I say we've got a winner
I've got a winner just realised look
five left we know come on out come on
out you are a champion you can bludgeon
us to death in bludgeon those three
actually if you would
[Music]
come on over sir I haven't got my emote
ready I'll do this for me steady
accolades royal accolades indeed do
anything celebratory if you would give
me a celebration a perfect and this is
your moment sir please point blanks
Knight me in the face well we have a
winner
his thumb okay Wow so I have to step in
here because this person is not the
winner let's travel back a storm circle
or to the player we thought one was
actually a very naughty boy first he
built a wall to stop my enforcer doing
his job and then he used a launch pad to
cheat the system
naughty naughty very naughty so you
forfeit your victory sir we are now
looking for the person who finished
second and this was extremely tight the
final three players were eliminated in
the same one-and-a-half seconds but as
you see from this shot the person who
finished second is else'll vini here's a
shot of the whole circle to prove it so
if you've stayed this long please throw
a GG in the chat for our winner else'll
vini please get in touch on discard an
hour add you to my friends list and gift
you something in the item shop
so that was one of the games from our
Meetup thanks for stopping by if you'd
like to get involved next time please
use code atom arrow in the shop like
these are some people on screen now that
support lets me host events like this
and reward winners and hopefully build a
positive community I'll throw the
discard link in the description below as
that's where we use voice chat I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade your awesome
I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]